so machine learning and data science are
really exciting fields to be in today
but what's the first thing you think
about when you think about machine
learning and data science ODS what oh
sorry no no you can call it out if you
want what do you think about what
getting the data okay okay that's one
thing um I generally think about
building a model but yeah getting the
data building a model these are kind of
what our minds like go to when we think
about these fields but this isn't the
whole picture there's a lot of other
tasks that go into the process of
building a model and as machine learning
and data science expand as fields some
of these tasks such as the
infrastructure to support model training
emerges their own subfields so hi I'm
Alexandra
I'm as was said I am the tech lead at
the platform team at sagat's and I'm
here tonight to talk about machine
learning infrastructure which is like I
said the subfield of machine learning
that is kind of devoted to what are the
infrastructure challenges unique to this
field I've talked to some of you tonight
and it sounds like there's people all
along the kind of like model building
journey from people who are just
learning to people who understand
complex topics such as hyper parameter
optimization so I hope that there will
be a little bit of something for
everyone
to learn about machine learning
infrastructure tonight I'm going to
start off with a history of the field
and kind of some of the people dynamics
that lead to machine learning
infrastructure emerging as it is today
next I'm gonna go into what is hyper
parameter optimization and how does that
introduce machine learning
infrastructure challenges and give you a
really grounded look at what several
different machine learning
infrastructure tools look like and the
technologies behind them and then lastly
I'm going to show you some examples of
successful machine learning
infrastructure projects either within
large companies or open source projects
that you could potentially use at your
company and end with some thoughts for
the future
when I think about machine learning
infrastructure I like to think about the
people who are in machine learning and
data science and the people who are in
infrastructure what are what are the
challenges these people are facing who
are they what did we hire them to do so
I thought this could be a little bit
participatory who do you think gets
hired into machine learning and data
science teams data scientists okay what
were what was the one in the back
problem solvers okay data scientist
problem solvers anything any other ideas
statisticians yeah that was my that was
my first answer yeah business liaisons
okay that that's when I didn't have out
there but I was thinking you know
statisticians perhaps people who are
PhDs in a scientific field they went
through a data science boot camp we've
got a lot of those in San Francisco but
mostly you think of people who love
building models people who are really
interested in getting their hands dirty
with data is one thing I've heard from a
lot of people and then what are we
asking these people to do so what are
things that people on data science and
machine learning teams do predict okay
my predictions white write sequel
queries okay okay yeah that's a big one
analyze data yeah yeah what clean up the
data okay yes extracting extracting
insights yeah yeah so this is when I
pulled so my co-workers about what our
customers are doing generally these kind
of emerge as trends we're asking people
to gather data build models and extract
insights and these are some of the
responsibilities that we're hiring
people for and then when we build the
mandate for the team generally success
for the team
looks like ML models in production
driving business decisions
so we're hiring to kind of like recap
we're hiring people who are interested
in building models were tasking them
with building models and then we're
telling them success looks like building
models so we've kind of built this data
science team together let's kind of talk
through what the process of actually
building a model looks like so if you're
a data scientist on this team and you
want to build a model you're gonna go
gather some data
you're gonna play around with the data
analyze it try to build some features do
the feature extraction step you're gonna
pick a pick an ml or data science
framework you're gonna train your model
and then you're gonna analyze results
and this is like a typical model
building workflow that a data scientist
can do in our Python in an ipython
notebook just in a normal IDE on their
laptop this is a pretty standard process
but what happens to our data scientists
when they encounter an out of memory
error this can happen for a lot of
different reasons maybe their data sets
too big maybe their data sets the right
size but once they build their feature
set that's too large or maybe the model
just grew to an intractable size
regardless of why the situation this now
puts our data scientists in is that they
can't train their model on their laptop
anymore they want to build a model but
now all of a sudden
the tool that they're generally given
their local workstation is not
sufficient so their workflows got to
change a little bit
now all the sudden we add these extra
steps you gather your data you extract
your features
you pick your ML framework but then you
have to go in spin up an AWS ec2
instance or you know like and then once
you spin out the instance you have to
set up the machines then you have to
remotely launch the training job on this
instance and then and only then can you
analyze your results but you know this
new workflow doesn't really look like
what we hired the data scientist to do
these tasks here highlighted in blue
look like kind of the responsibilities
that we hire the data scientists for but
these extra ones are better categorized
as infrastructure work the point here is
that now the data scientist is in a
situation of being asked to do work
that's pretty different from the
responsibilities that were laid out when
the team was formed the responsibilities
that were laid out when they were hired
and you know okay maybe it's fair to say
you've got one data scientist and
they're trying to build models using one
AWS ec2 machine is it really that much
of a big deal if you're already
proficient in building models it may
only take you a day to learn how to do
this and actually requiring a data
scientist to know a little bit of
infrastructure isn't actually going to
be detrimental to your data science team
it may be appropriate the issue comes
when the infrastructure scales the issue
comes when we ask our data scientists to
not only be experts in data science but
we also ask for them to be experts in
infrastructure as well because
infrastructure is its own separate
specialty in computer science and these
are just examples of some of the reasons
why our infrastructure might scale maybe
you have like we're talking about large
data sets features models that lead to
out of memory errors but maybe you just
have a large team of data scientists and
every single one of them wants to be
able to close their laptop when they go
home
and still be able to monitor their
training progress maybe you need access
to specialized hardware like GPUs or
something like that in all of these
cases the infrastructure is scaling to
be very large and we're left asking the
question is it fair to ask the data
scientists to manage all this
infrastructure but if the data scientist
isn't handling their infrastructure who
is responsible for spinning up and
managing the data scientists
infrastructure well we have a guess of
who we could ask it's in the name you
know we could ask the infrastructure
team perhaps the infrastructure team is
able to help out the data science team
which is why I want to go back to the
people who form these teams data science
and like in large corporations data
science teams are relatively new as they
kind of exist today but infrastructure
teams are a little bit more established
infrastructure teams have a little bit
of a different way that they work so we
talk through who we have on these
infrastructure teams and what their
responsibilities are for these already
established teams we're seeing that
we're hiring people like systems experts
and back-end engineers and what we're
asking them to do is we're asking them
to be responsible for reliability
scalability and performance now this
seems honestly like a pretty good match
these seem based on what we're seeing
here these seem like people who our data
scientist could ask for help from but
here's where the tricky part comes in
the infrastructure team having already
been around for a while at the company
has their hands full with other
responsibilities in my work as an
infrastructure engineer at cig apt we're
responsible for fulfilling customer
service level agreements and keeping our
API and website up and running to a
certain level of uptime specification
and infrastructure engineers at other
companies may be organized around
similar objectives
the point is the data science team is
still feeling this pain and the
infrastructure team may have the
expertise but they've already got their
hands full with a lot of other things
they've got a list of pre-existing
objectives and they're not just sitting
around waiting for extra work so it's in
this environment that machine learning
infrastructure emerges as its own
subfield the work that we're asking for
the work that we're asking out of
machine learning infrastructure is
nominally some of the same kind of
infrastructure expertise and tooling
that we've had before but we're asking
to apply it in a pretty different way
helping data scientists build tools is
pretty different from keeping an API up
and running it requires different
workloads it sometimes requires
different technologies and there's a lot
of exciting new challenges so machine
learning infrastructure has emerged as
this kind of confluence of data science
and machine learning users and workloads
plus infrastructure and DevOps tools and
expertise and this is a field that I am
really excited about because I think
there's a lot of really cool challenges
here
so I've kind of talked about who are the
people who are on these data science and
machine learning teams and who are the
people on these infrastructure teams and
why can't they just all help each other
out I've kind of given a little bit of
context as to why the machine learning
infrastructure field has arisen today
now what I want to give you is a
grounded look at some different machine
learning infrastructure tools and some
of the technologies that were used to
build these tools so I'm going to
introduce hyper parameter optimization
and the infrastructure challenges and
then show you what it looks like when a
data science team builds their own tools
and then show you what it looks like
when an infrastructure team overhauls
some of those tools quick show of hands
how many of you have heard of hyper
parameter optimization before okay cool
every model has hyper parameters hyper
parameters are the configurable values
that you set on your model before you
begin to train with any data different
settings of hyper parameters have a very
large impact on the performance of your
model and hyper parameter optimization
abbreviated hpo because it is very
difficult to say a lot is the search for
the best set of hyper parameters it's
the search for the set of hyper
parameters that produces the best
performance for your model these are
some example hyper parameters if you've
ever built a random forest model you may
have been left wondering how do I set
the values for the number of trees in a
forest how do I set the values for the
maximum depth per tree and you can use
Hyper parameter optimization to help you
figure out which values for a number of
trees in a forest or maximum depth per
tree can help you maximize the accuracy
of your random forest model and this is
true of almost any model out there you
can use hyper parameter optimization to
help you figure out which configuration
values will produce the best performance
for your model
Hyper parameter optimization is a great
challenge for machine learning
infrastructure because it essentially
trades off compute power for model
performance hyper parameter optimization
can help get you to the upper echelons
of model performance but it may require
in kind of the upper echelon zuv model
compute as well if you're used to
training your model one time and your
model has ten high per parameters you
may need to train your model a hundred
times to find the best set of hyper
parameters for your model and that's
with some of the more sophisticated
methods if your model takes an hour to
train this means that you're going to be
left waiting about four days to receive
your results which and kind of like work
time means that it's going to take you
all week to kind of set up this
experiment wait for results and analyze
it and when something's sitting around
for an entire week running in the
background that can be kind of
distracting so we're left with this
situation where we want to get the
maximum performance out of our model we
want to use Hyper parameter optimization
to get the maximum performance out of
our model we're running into a situation
where hyper parameter optimization wants
to train our model a hundred times and
that's taking a whole week so we can
paralyze we can paralyze the model
training across six different machines
to reduce the wall clock time that means
instead of waiting around for results
for a week we're only waiting around for
results on the order of a day and I
don't know about you guys but for me
that would be a lot less distracting a
lot easier to kind of like on a human
level manage this process going back to
my earlier point though you see that we
want to paralyze hyper parameter
optimization to six machines who is
responsible for spinning up and managing
these six machines is it fair to ask the
data scientist to spin up and manage
those six machines so your mileage may
vary and
I'm gonna show you what it looks like
when data scientists build tools and
when infrastructure engineers build
tools to help kind of manage the process
of starting hyper parameter optimization
jobs these both have kind of like a
common theme where the problem they're
trying to solve is getting code and
dependencies onto a remote machine onto
a remote machine starting jobs and then
monitoring the progress data scientists
build tools that they trust in 2017
every new machine learning project at
Sega was producing a new machine
learning tool that was handcrafted for
that data scientists or a person doing
the data science project and that
particular project so each kind of like
folder in our examples repository would
have a different set of code for
spinning up machines and doing that
process I talked about getting code onto
the remote machines launching the job
and viewing the progress what this meant
was that each machine learning project
was taking time out of that project to
write this specialty code in an area of
computer science that wasn't related to
the goal of the project and this code
was being kind of repeated by every
person additionally what you'll see is
that the tools that ended up being
produced
we're kind of an afterthought the tools
was kind of the tools were kind of the
easiest thing that could be built to get
the job done so what do these tools look
like
to solve the first problem of getting
code and dependencies from your local
laptop to the 6 remote instances you
would SCP everything everywhere you'd
use SCP to send every single file from
your workstation to every single remote
machine that met if you close your
laptop at any point during this process
you could lose all of your progress
because these tools didn't do a great
job of keeping track of the progress for
launching jobs these tools generally use
SSH to run remote to run commands on
remote instances you can use SSH to both
login to an instance and run a command
yourself but you can also use it to
automatically send a command to a remote
machine to run finally for viewing
progress and debugging jobs well sigit
provides an API for hyper parameter
optimization so all of the tools would
use the sagat's api to help track
metadata about the job and then they
would also run remote jobs on remote
instances in T max windows so what's
happening is that each remote instance
is training the model over and over and
over again on different sets of hyper
parameters so when you use T max to run
a process on a remote instance if that
job fails you can SSH on to this
instance you can open up the T MUX
window and you can see a record of all
the logs and the stack trace from the
failed process so it was better than
having nothing kind of rudimentary
debugging tools
as I said data scientists built tools
that they trusted when you are kind of
wearing the data science hat on your
project you wanted to build something as
quickly as possible but what this kind
of led to in retrospect is people built
tools that they really understood people
built tools that they had full control
over when you built a machine learning
infrastructure tool for your project you
understood exactly what was going on you
had full kind of autonomy to do whatever
you wanted you didn't have to ask anyone
else to implement a new feature for you
you didn't have to ask anyone else to
debug something for you you could figure
it all out on your own but while these
tools were very usable by the individual
data scientists who wrote them some of
the problems lay on kind of the
infrastructure and team fundamentals
side it was difficult to share tools
between different people so every
project would end up needing to spend
those extra couple of days to build a
new tool again and this seems pretty
simple but you couldn't close your
laptop while some of this stuff was
running and being able to being able to
have a job run asynchronously on
different machines actually becomes a
big deal when there's a lot of different
things you're doing additionally this
kind of process of needing to
communicate with each machine
individually to send over code or to
start jobs it worked fine for one or two
machines but this doesn't scale well to
a hundred machines the point is that the
data science tool was customized for
that person but it still had some some
features that were maybe not so great on
the infrastructure side so the next
thing we looked at was asking the
infrastructure engineers to overhaul
these data science tools which is where
I want to leave you with this caveat
I thought that this quote did a great
job of explaining the kind of caveats
behind just across the board introducing
shared services creating shared services
also creates dependencies and can
impinge on autonomy these data
scientists were building tools that let
them have a large degree of autonomy by
having the infrastructure team come in
and build a shared tool then we're going
to lose a little bit of that autonomy so
that's just something to think about
if you're considering maybe introducing
shared tools or building shared tools
for your organization because I'm going
to talk about how that played out a
little bit when I get to the pros and
cons section but I always like to bring
it back to kind of like who are the
users who are the people who are going
to be using these tools
so I got to be the tech lead for the
infrastructure engineer overhaul in 2018
we started the projects I got to
orchestrate which had nominally the same
kind of process goals as the previous
data science tools we wanted to be able
to quickly spin up and manage hyper
parameter optimization jobs because well
if you can't tell already hyper
parameter optimization is a big focus
that's ago so the infrastructure people
busy did we get new infrastructure
people so I think this was a little bit
of a function of the team was growing so
we had a couple of new people on the
team but then also we decided to step
back and say hey this seems to be a
pretty big need in our organization
we're going to carve out dedicated time
to inform like it's a separate sub team
to be dedicated to this effort and so it
wasn't part of the like standard
infrastructure roadmap it was definitely
its own separate effort that existed
independently but that's a good question
because as I'll talk about in the kind
of future notes section I would
definitely recommend building these
things as their own dedicated efforts
because the infrastructure work is is
different enough so the infrastructure
engineers myself included got to use
kind of the latest and greatest in
infrastructure technologies to try to
solve some of these issues if you're not
familiar with containerization you can
think of a of a container as kind of a
recipe for kind of installing and
managing your development environment so
it includes your dependencies and your
code and you'll often hear the term
docker come up because docker is the
most popular containerization technology
available today although it is not the
only one so the benefit of using
containerization is that you package up
all your code and all your dependencies
to train your model one
on your local laptop you send this one
time to a container registry and I'm
using the term container and image
interchangeably and then each each
machine in the cloud will download the
container or the image from the registry
itself what this means is that the kind
of interacting with each machine
individually is all happening behind the
scenes
no more needing to leave your laptop
open for any more than just building
your container and pushing it to a
registry to solve the problem of
launching jobs we used kubernetes
specifically because we run on AWS
we used AWS s e KS which is their
managed kubernetes service kubernetes
provides kind of a way of turning your
machines into a cluster and then it also
provides a nice set of api's and
abstraction layers for things like
launching jobs specifically kubernetes
operates on the promise of container
orchestration so it's very well-suited
to launching jobs that are based on
containers and since we had committed
set containers and kind of like the last
step it was a natural choice to want to
use kubernetes because we had used
darker and kubernetes in this tool it
was easier to build debugging and
monitoring tools docker and kubernetes
have these kind of rich communities
behind them and so they've got a lot of
great abstractions and it's easy to
build really powerful stuff on top of
them so we packaged up our tool is a
command line interface we built
abstraction layers on top of docker and
kubernetes to allow you to view status
at a glance in the command line and to
view your logs
but this tool was not without its
problems it had a great amount of
promise but it didn't do a perfect job
of connecting with the people who were
supposed to use it yes it solved these
problems of kind of reliability
scalability and performance it provided
what were in theory great debugging
tools it was highly scalable it was easy
to install but you took away a little
bit of that autonomy and this tool took
away a little bit of that freedom that
the data scientists were used to having
as I heard from someone who used it they
said you know I'm actually not that
comfortable spinning up infrastructure
but when I build my own tool I know
exactly what's going on and so I trust
that tool when you introduce this
abstraction layer on top of docker and
kubernetes well it's difficult for me to
understand what's going on and it's
difficult for me to trust that I'm not
making a mistake
that's going to cost the company
thousands of dollars additionally we had
an external dependency not only was it
more difficult for the data scientists
to trust the tool but they would have to
go to another team if they wanted to
solve bugs or if they wanted new
features built so it was a little bit it
was more difficult to use than had been
anticipated and you kind of had these
these things that play like trust and
how much do your users understand
infrastructure and how much do they want
to enter understand about infrastructure
data scientists built tools they trusted
infrastructure engineers built tools
around infrastructure principles so how
can we kind of combine these two
different views and produce great
machine learning infrastructure tools
going forwards in my opinion the most
critical thing to producing great
machine learning infrastructure tools is
going to be a tight feedback loop with
your user it's going to be very
important for these teams to develop
user empathy and you can only do that by
talking to your user again and again and
again as an infrastructure engineer it
was easy for me to get lost in the
problem and to get lost in the idea of
I'm building a technical tool for
technical people I understand what I'm
comfortable with
therefore I can build this tool to what
I'm comfortable with
it had worked for me before but when it
comes to machine learning infrastructure
tools your user set is pretty different
data science and infrastructure as I
said are two different specialties
within computer science and within the
technology industry at large they have
different people that are hired for each
role different responsibilities and
different objectives and it helps to
treat them differently when you're going
to build the tool and so it's important
to talk to your users again and again
and have them dog food these tools which
means having users kind of internal to
your team use the tools as you're
developing this is my hypothesis the
tight user feedback loop is my
hypothesis as to why some of the most
successful machine learning
infrastructure projects today are coming
out of teams at large companies I'm
hypothesizing that it's because the
machine learning infrastructure teams
have ready and easy access to the data
science users because they're building
products for an internal team although
some of these have plans to be open
sourced and some of them may have been
open sourced already I know that
Google's Borg project which is a little
bit more general was turned into
kubernetes
but I do think that there will be some
startups emerging startups who are
dedicated to machine learning
infrastructure can get this type
feedback loop by working very closely
with their customers and I'm really
excited to see what's on the horizon in
the next 5-10 years when it comes to
machine learning infrastructure I also
want to give some love to the open
source machine learning infrastructure
projects out there many of these are
based on kubernetes clusters as a
back-end but these are all available for
you to kind of use within your
organization right now I have written
and spoken on this topic before if
you're interested in learning more about
the cig up orchestrate tool me and my
colleague Mike McCourt have written a
paper there's a blog post on machine
learning infrastructure and I gave a
similar talk for ML conf NYC this year
so what I'd like you to kind of take
away is a little bit about the dynamics
but behind how these infant mission
learning infrastructure tools are built
data scientists build tools they trust
infrastructure engineers build tools
that are robust how we can kind of move
towards a future where we're building
robust tools that are trusted is by
having a tight user feedback loop and by
talking very frequently to the people
who will be using these tools last thing
if you are interested in talking more
and maybe in letting me come by your
office and seeing how you work I'm gonna
be around an arbor until 5:00 p.m.
tomorrow and I would love to kind of see
you in your environment and see what's
going on so if you're in this area and
want to talk further please reach out
and thank you so much for having me pie
data and Arbor and I can now take a few
questions
yes so at Sega so the question was do I
have any thoughts on ml4 Kubb flow and
am i using them in my company so at cig
apt we build an API for hyper parameter
optimization so generally when we do
data science projects it's to either
write a blog post to showcase the power
of hyper parameter optimization or to
help our customers who are attempting to
build models and show them the value of
hyper parameter optimization so we use
orchestrate internally or the home built
tools that the data scientists have done
we don't have any plans to adopt those
larger tools because we don't have a
data science pipeline to support it yes
so the question was have you looked into
agile type project management tools to
help with that tight user feedback loop
and you know what I would say for this
is we are a very small start-up we're
about 25 peoples we have not yet
introduced agile but that sound
something like that sort of process
where you've got a full dedicated team
effort that has maybe its own product
manager and its own engineers to build
machine learning infrastructure tools is
something like what I would recommend so
agile would be a great thing to look
into for machine learning infrastructure
tools specifically what the benefits
that would provide is regularly talking
to users and a little bit more structure
around scoping out these projects yes
many engineering areas
yeah I am from the Bay Area so your
question was how would I define the job
scope of a machine learning engineer so
what I would say is that job scope
varies wildly from company to company
and so I would read that company if
you're interested in a particular
company you're interested in what does
it mean to be an a machine learning
engineer that company you're gonna need
to read that company's Job Description
to figure out what it is historically
people with the title machine learning
engineer have taken on a little bit more
of this infrastructure responsibility
than people with the title data
scientist but what I'm seeing is that
that's sort of breaking out and they're
becoming their own team so yeah you're
gonna have to check on a company by
company basis and that's just because
the industry so the question was did you
consider having an infrastructure
engineer sit on the data science team or
having a data scientist sit on the
infrastructure team and see what you
could produce that is something I would
definitely recommend for other people
who want to build tools like this again
we're small and we're pretty resource
constrained so that wasn't necessarily a
resource that we could that we could
devote at the time yes
the users get any say of how much like
paralyzation what kind of machine will
be spun up because they will get to
build and if it's yes I want the results
fast but I can want a lot of procedure
in parallel but they don't forget about
to build so is there a way for users of
Sega to kind of see where my resource
build would be yeah so the question was
using a machine learning infrastructure
tool like stick up orchestrate does the
user have control over which machines
are being spun up and how many machines
are being spun up and from that does the
user have any control over how much
their experiment is going to cost so the
answer is yes the user has total control
over how much their experiment is going
to cost all of the model training is
done within the users environment and
they specify the type of machine and the
number of machine when you say
production level does that mean
production Eliza models and serving
results so our product doesn't currently
we're focused on helping people what the
question was do these infrastructure
tools carry on to the production ization
of machine learning models which is
generally scoped to mean you have a
machine learning model and it's may be
accessible via an API and someone
outside of that team can hit it and ask
for results
the answer is our tool doesn't some
tools do focus on that that is a we
focus on the problem of helping people
launch hyper parameter optimization jobs
but the process of production Eliza
models is a big part of the industry and
that's what some tools are focused on
we're not sharing like for the notebooks
the common code sharing how do you
orchestrate that
and so that it can be shared for
different tasks that you don't have to
rewrite because that was one of the
paint words I heard from the data
scientists that they had to read
everybody has to write a similar code
and have to and then waste time on not
sure yeah so the question was how do you
solve the problem of sharing code maybe
across different ipython notebooks and
that I would say is a longer answer I
would I don't have much expertise in
that area but I'd love to hear a little
bit more maybe offline about your
particular problems that you're facing
sorry can you repeat that question yes
so the question was about what's the
method of hyper parameter optimization
so the answer is there's many different
methods for performing hyper parameter
optimization when you're just trying out
different configurations of hyper
parameters on your own
that's called manual optimization when
you're enumerate n't possible values of
say for different parameters on a sort
of grid that's called grid search at sig
opt use a technique called Bayesian
optimization that underlies our hyper
parameter optimization and Bayesian
optimization is a very popular technique
within hyper parameter optimization
today it allows you to see better
results faster than manual tuning or
than great and random search bayesian
optimization please don't ask me to
spell it still have anxiety from the
fourth grade spelling bee okay so the
question was how is this machine
learning infrastructure different from
auto ml platforms like Amazon Sage Maker
so that's a great question a lot of
these machine learning infrastructure
tools look different on the surface but
when you kind of peek in you see that
while there's a lot of tasks in machine
learning
you can almost like make these check
boxes as to what are all the tasks and
how many of them does each tool handle
so a tool like say got orchestrate is
going to handle a very low number of
those tasks it's going to only see check
marks in the boxes of spinning up
machines launching jobs and monitoring
hyper parameter optimization jobs but a
tool like AWS sage maker is going to
have check boxes in a lot for a lot more
features eight I understand the AWS sage
maker helps you with a much larger part
of the kind of model building and
production Allah zation pipeline where
this comes into play is that different
teams have different requirements for
things like
what Amazon is allowed to see you know
if you're Walmart and you can't use AWS
sage maker but also if you're a team
that maybe can't let their data leave
their machines then you're not going to
want to then you're going to want to use
a tool that handles less of the process
for you and so it's really all about
like what's the feature set and then for
your team the question is how much of
this feature set are you comfortable
letting another company handle for you
we're on kind of the very lightweight
side Atos stage makers on the very
heavyweight side and there are use cases
for both no want to see some slides well
that question is for either current
customers or potential customers what
should they be looking forward to and
your food retzig off whether product
line oh sure yeah so this is a good
point cuz I know a lot of you are coming
from University of Michigan and the
Midas group but Sagat is free for
academic users so if you are a current
student and you are interested in using
sig opt sign up online I don't know what
the current process is but email the
email address that you're given and you
can get free access if you're an
academic user for use in your projects
and then some of the interesting things
to look forward to are more tools for
being able to kind of monitor your
progress as you're training your machine
learning job so if you're doing this
heavy-duty model training like I'm
talking about you're gonna have kind of
like more insights into what your models
doing while you're training it improved
UI UX features like that we've also had
a lot of great stuff come out recently
around the dashboard grouping and team
collaboration tools that the platform
team has been working very hard on you
would learn a lot we also try to
remember that empathy really is a key
part of being sore
in the thena science field right and so
with that lets thank alexander for
another one